as we head towards an epic face-off
between the Avengers and Thanos and
Avengers infinity war it's crucial to
keep track of what's going on with the
Infinity stones and dr. Strange's solo
movie reveals an important new piece and
the Infinity stones puzzle
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and I'm going to talk about a cool
infinity stone reveal from Doctor
Strange and give you a full update on
the status of all six Infinity stones
and the marvel cinematic universe just
so you're aware there will be spoilers
coming up for Doctor Strange so if you
haven't seen the movie yet or want to
avoid those click here for my spoiler
free movie review ok let's first recap
the key updates we get in Doctor Strange
about the Infinity stones the movie
reveals that the eye of agamotto holds
an infinity stone the time stone in fact
as its name suggests the time stone has
the power to manipulate the space-time
continuum and we first see this after
strange uses the eye of agamotto to cast
a spell where he moves an apple
backwards and forwards in time from hole
to eat and and decays and back to whole
again strange even uses it to restore
the stolen pages from the book of Kali
Ostrow and there's that sudden moment
work columns of glass or crystal shoots
up in front of him disappearing as Wonga
Mordo burst in and scold him for the
dangers of manipulating the space-time
continuum so there's an interesting bit
of foreshadowing in the scene with Mordo
warning strange against getting stuck in
a time loop which of course is a trick
that strange uses later against Dormammu
and the mirrored images that pop up
suggest that strange is peeking into
visions of alternate timelines by the
way even when timer spells aren't being
cast the movie still plays on the theme
of time with lingering shots of
strangers collection of expensive
watches and with strange asking dr. West
to cover his watch during an operation
later in the movie Doctor Strange again
opens the eye of agamotto in Hong Kong
using the time stone to roll back
significant events in time restoring
demolished buildings and even bringing
Wong back to life and during his
confrontation with Dormammu strange
himself also cheats death with the
creation of a time loop these scenes
were visually very cool and impressive
but the resurrection that the time
stones seems to allow has wider
implications for the MCU for example
could it bring back a Ford an Avenger
like Quicksilver obviously there are
risks to using the time stone Mordo as
opposed to using it in the film as it's
against natural
and morose words that the bill comes due
could be foreshadowing Stannis getting
cold as a time stone as Wang said news
of the Ancient Ones death will spread
rapidly through the multiverse and
Thanos may also detected strange using
the stone in the doct I mention as we
know he's tracking where all the stones
are by the way talking of Mordo going
forward to keep a lookout for the staff
of the Living Tribunal which more
dimension when explaining magical relics
to dr. strange the Living Tribunal is a
character in the Marvel comic book
multiverse with power that eclipses even
that of the Infinity Gauntlet and the
way mato gave a special mention to the
staff of the Living Tribunal could mean
that we'll see this relic all that
character come into play in infinity war
so now that we've seen the time stone in
action Wong and strange have decided to
leave the eye of agamotto in a room that
was already broken into by Chi Silius
and his sellers if it stays there it's
not hard to imagine how panis will get
his hands on it and what about the other
five stones well we've got four others
accounted for so far the space stone the
reality stone the power stone and the
mind stone the space stone also known as
a tesseract can act as an energy source
and also opens up portals in space to
allow teleportation between worlds it
was harnessed by [ __ ] in the first
Captain America movie stolen from shield
by Loki and the Avengers and last seen
being taken back to Asgard by Thor at
the end of that movie and stored in
Odin's treasure room but with Loki
masquerading as Odin at the end of Thor
the dark world could the stone have
already fallen into the wrong hands the
reality stone aka the ether is extremely
powerful and was wielded by Malekith in
Thor the dark world the ether takes on a
liquid form rather than a solid state
and Odin has said it can convert matter
into dark matter it's not completely
clear yet what else it can do but it is
extremely dangerous as it reputedly has
the power to destroy the whole universe
ironically given that he seems a pretty
shady character it was handed over for
safekeeping to taneli Atavan aka the
collector the end of Thor the dark world
although events later in guardians of
the galaxy led to an explosion at two
vans collection so it's unknown whether
the reality stone is still in his
possession
and it was the guardians of the galaxy
who introduced the Power Stone which
Thanos had ordered Ronan the accuser to
obtain for him the power stone as its
name suggests is incredibly powerful and
can even destroy a whole planet if it
falls into the wrong hands it was handed
over to the Nova Corps at the end of
guardians of the galaxy who put it in
their vault for supposed safekeeping in
the comics the Nova Corps derived much
of their power from the Nova Force
so maybe the Nova Corps might try to
harness the energy from the Power Stone
the mine stone has featured in both
Avengers movies so far first brought to
earth by Loki in a scepter and used to
mind-control Hawk I'm after it fell into
the hands of Hydra it was used to
harness the latent powers of Scarlet
Witch and Quicksilver and later after
Tony Stark recovered it it was one of
the elements used to bring vision to
life and the mine stone is currently
embedded in visions forehead the stone
we haven't seen yet the sole stone will
presumably show up in one of the film's
before Avengers infinity war or in
infinity war itself in the comics the
soul stone is sentient hungers for other
souls and it has the power over life and
death all of which mean it's a good
candidate for turning up in Thor
Ragnarok which will introduce Kate
Blanchette as the supernatural villain
hella hella is nurse Guardian goddess
queen of Hell and has a history of
stealing Souls in the comics all of
which could mean in the movie that she
either already has a stone or knows
where it is and is going to steal it
there was a scene from hell's teased in
spores vision in Avengers age of Ultron
and Thor also had a vision of the
Infinity stones which he decided to
investigate at the end of that Avengers
movie all of which points to an
important infinity stone reveal in Thor
Ragnarok by the way there's also a
theory that Heimdall possesses the soul
stone which could be indicated by his
glowing orange eyes and that the soul
stone can be seen in his armor so guys
we now have the location of the time
stone in the MCU confirmed but we're
still missing the soul stone so what
movie do you think it's going to show up
in and what are your predictions for how
Stannis is going to get hold of all six
stones I always enjoy reading your
thoughts in the comments below if you
liked this video and it's your first
time here I'd love it if you'd subscribe
and you can also take a look at more of
my Marvel video
in my playlist right here or check out
my full guide to all the Easter eggs and
Doctor Strange click on the links below
to check them out thanks for watching
and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers